bien Jacques delard je vous repose ma
question du début de l'émission est-ce
que vous êtes oui ou non candidat à
l'élection présidentielle par exception
je vais lire c'est ce qui est rare chez
moi puisque même mes exposés je l'ai
fait d'habitude à partir de peu de notes
comme beaucoup le savent je n'ai jamais
organisé ma vie en fonction d'une
carrière à réaliser ou de poste à
conquérir j'ai toujours essayé de
choisir de travailler de militer là où
j'estimais être le plus utile pour les
valeurs que je défends pour la société
et pour mon pays et c'est dans ce même
esprit que j'ai orienté mes réflexions
de ces derniers mois j'ai décidé de ne
pas être candidat à la présidence de la
République ce n'est pas une décision qui
fut facile à prendre je voudrais donc
l'expliquer le plus simplement possible
autant le dire d'emblé de la manière la
plus claire beaucoup de raisons
personnelles me poussaient à dire non je
vais atteindre 70 ans je travaille sans
relâche depuis 50 ans il est plus
raisonnable dans ces conditions
d'envisager un mode de vie plus
équilibré entre la réflexion et l'action